please welcome marley matlin troy cutzer
and their interpreters jack and justin
[Applause]
hello nice to meet you
um jack and i have known each other for
and marley and marley obviously
actually marley how long have we
known each other
well
uh we've known each other really a long
time a long time probably then we
actually realized uh do you remember how
we met do you remember when we met yes
yes
let me tell you let me tell the story
yes okay go
ready ready okay here we go
so uh we were in the uh
it was a bar it was called the columbus
bar and grill and it was the night of
this crazy award ceremony that we went
to with my old boyfriend who won that
night
and william hurt and michael douglas
raul julia yes i knew it yes and so
we got into the bar it was like one in
the morning and i was a little bit sort
of buzzed but anyway uh
more than necessary really um
and we walked in we sat down
and
someone comes up and says hi
welcome
what would you like to drink
and i looked
i was like what
e.t
no i was so thrown it was you all of you
this big this big
and william hurt flipped out when he saw
you because you guys did a movie
together oh my gosh so he played
he was mad that's right in fact what's
the problem did he
did he hold me up yeah i think he did it
yes
yeah
because i played his daughter in
alternate state
and yes he treated me like his daughter
that's right yeah i remember that yeah
he was mad at me and he held me up yeah
it was a very interesting journey since
then it's been an interesting journey
since then but since that moment
i remember many times and many years
feeling very comfortable and safe with
you
which me too the world wasn't always so
comfortable and safe i know i know but
when i was with you yeah
i appreciate that you said that and i
was so excited to see you
and
i
love this film
so much
and
troy
first of all your performance is so
beautiful
and
i loved that you had watched marley win
the
oscar for best actress um
is that 1987
five years ago yeah exactly
around that time i was a senior in high
school
so you can do the math and figure out
what my age was
35 years ago 35 years ago what she said
it was the first time i saw
authentic deaf representation on screen
in children of a lesser god it really
inspired me and i felt connected and it
really gave me hope as an actor to
pursue acting
and so i continued for many years as an
actor
and it led me to get to this point and
it's been truly amazing to finally work
with marley she's just a foot away from
me right now
and i never thought that would happen
[Applause]
and you have
that chemistry
and troy you're making history now
yourself as being the first deaf actor
to be nominated
and
thank you
love you all
when you see this film this is a
no-brainer
but how is the full circle moment being
next to marley who inspired you back
then
well it was such an interesting timeline
for me so marley was very young won the
award and i was inspired and i remained
true to my vision i
was patient with all the frustration and
politics and oppression and all that and
finally reached this point looking at
her i finally feel like we understand
each other we are able to share this
journey and this experience together and
help each other out and help hollywood
to begin to improve opening their minds
to begin thinking outside the box and
all those types of things because
the deaf community has so many stories
to tell you know for troy i think i
think knowing after 35 years since i won
the oscar
and i've seen so much and i've
plowed through all the
i mean it's been an interesting journey
uh really a wonderful one
but at the same time compared to might
have you know what might have happened
in the past up to now i think no more
eyes are open more ears are open more
people are aware of our community of our
culture
our beautiful language american sign
language
and there's a lot more
opportunities
and yet there's still more work to do
but one thing i've been seeing
is
there is more collaboration
there are deaf actors directors writers
who are working with those of us in the
business who happen to be working with
us so we're collaborating and i think
collaboration is the key these days
[Music]